radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert is getting a
divorce I don't personally think there's
anything wrong with divorce but you've
got to look at bobert's past statements
and realize that this is a serious
hypocrite that we are dealing with
Lauren bobert frequently has invoked her
Christian Faith and family values in
political rhetoric and part of that
includes that you don't get divorced and
she's even talked about how the
Christian thing to do is you work
through the problem or whatever the case
may be Lauren bobert has criticized
other elected officials for marital
issues like Hillary Clinton staying with
Bill Clinton after Bill Clinton had an
affair that is an instance of hypocrisy
this is a hypocrite it is not a
criticism of her personal life it's a
criticism of how she judges others and
the hypocrisy that is now standard for
these right Wingers